now it's your turn to write the code to
query for all conferences you're going
to need to add the query conferences
method in the conference API class
you're going to need to identify the
function as an endpoint method that uses
HTTP POST and if you can't remember how
to do that just look at some of the
other functions in the file and
implement query conferences to return
all conferences sorted by name and when
you've written your function go ahead
and test it on localhost and that is
important it's really important that you
test on localhost first don't cheat
don't deploy direct to appspot you'll
find if you do that it probably won't
work after you run it on localhost go
ahead and try out the query you can
either do that and the api's explorer or
you can go to the show conferences page
it doesn't matter which way you do it
but make sure that you run it on
localhost first and then after you've
tested it on localhost I do want you to
deploy it to appspot
now we're going to check that your
application actually works and that it
does create conferences and queries
conferences I want you to go ahead and
create a conference called Udacity
that's going to take place in London
it's important that you get these right
that you're at the name is actually
Udacity spell write and that the city is
in London otherwise our testing script
might not work and then go ahead and
enter your app ID here this needs to be
the app ID of the app that's running on
appspot